and tonight we'll be looking at the idea
of trading so obviously it's a big part
of chess is when pieces come off the
board
suddenly the pieces that remain on the
board have you know different roles and
positions and it can change and we'll
look at you know when we want to trade
pieces and what kind of pieces should
you trade and things of that nature so I
got four puzzles tonight that we'll take
a look at and the first one this so this
is the one we'll actually watch this
whole game
it'll be Anatoly Karpov versus Joe la
tierra from bill 1992 and this one we
will watch the whole game though we're
going to just breeze through the opening
here it was a semi Slav so if you're
we're here on Monday night and then we
got our big semi Slav lectures okay and
in a normal semi soft position like this
he plays very positionally because he's
Karpov he gets the movie four in and
after a few more moves Bishop f4 and
it's all about trading so he trades lots
of stuff and we reach this position so
let's pause here for a minute and as
always when we see a new position like
this I kind of like to evaluate the
position so I want to give you guys a
minute at home you can go ahead and
pause your video if you want to think
about this position how would you assess
this like who's better why
you know what Trump's to each side have
what disadvantages do they have that
wasn't intentional Yeah right now that
now we got to banned this video because
it's election night and that wasn't that
wasn't on purpose yeah yeah exactly why
it has more space perfect that's one one
big plus
flex pieces are all really connected ok
yeah so equal share of the D file both
players have equal access to the D file
how would you compare the bishops
black's bishop is horrible right so
obviously what black needs to do to make
his bishop not horrible is play the move
c5 if you place the move c5 then all of
his pieces are good that solves all of
his problems so we want to thank
prophylactically here so how did Karpov
prevent the move c5 so you could you
could play a move like c5 however if we
look at the weakness of the last move
you've kind of given me access to the
square I can drop my knight my rook in
here this should be OK for me because
I'm attacking all of your pawns you know
if you just play off four I'm going to
take on c5 or whatever you want to do so
that is an interesting idea but it's
it's not quite the strongest move yeah
yeah awesome
Bishop f3 sorry my voice
Bishop f3 preventing c5 okay black still
he's like okay I need to play c5 with my
bishops only protected ones so I'll go
back to the eighth rank okay next move I
play c5 and so here
Karpov actually did an interesting thing
by kind of breaking a rule that we've
probably all been taught at some point
and that's kind of we're going to look
at examples today of trades where you
sort of break a conventional rule you
know you don't want to get too caught up
in like chest Dogma and thinking to
dogmatically about any position you want
to think okay in this exact concrete
position I really want to emphasize how
bad this Bishop is that's what I'm
playing for the only way I'm going to
you know have a decent advantage here
with white is if I can keep him passive
forever but obviously he's just ready to
play c5 so who here can play like Karpov
yeah rook takes d8 yeah and in general
you don't want to just concede a file
however here he has a very concrete idea
so black took back with his rook okay so
still c5 is coming rook to d1 yes this
is very interesting because okay you
challenge the file but now after we take
back you've had to put your Bishop on a
worse square you had to go all the way
back to d1 + senses blacks turn now he
gets to seize the D file so okay kind of
a rule is don't give up the files and
here we can see the Queen is going to be
coming down somewhere obviously we're
attacking the bishop so the bishop moves
back to f3 still preventing c5 and now
the Queen gets to come in so this is
what happens when you give up files
there pieces get really active and for
the moment we're threatening to win your
B pond and now this next maneuver is
really awesome and this is you know this
is what Karpov is good at so here you
may want to pause your video see if you
can find the nice little sequence that
Karpov came up with and it's these
little little tiny brilliance ease that
you know they really that really
impresses me when I watch Karpov games
it's these little ideas so yeah go ahead
and you guys will get a couple minutes
here
Queen h4 okay this is a very interesting
move the move Queen h4 though it looks
like it does have one problem so your
point is if I take here I might get
checkmated maybe but I think actually I
do have time to get away with this check
which forces you here and I can grab
this guy g3 or or King back whatever you
want to do now I should be able to I can
play f6 or drop my Queen back or
whatever I whatever I got to do to not
get back rang made it and I snatched a
pun and kind of a more important one you
know this this epon and in these
structures well these often it often
ends up will go back to this position
that this Indian end game actually can
be a really big weakness it's either a
strength because you're taking more
space and cramping your opponent or you
know in a position like this you can see
we can check you and take your pawn so
can actually end up sometimes backfiring
and and be a weakness another common
move that I've heard people suggest when
I was out in the club just showing this
to people because that's how I prepare I
just show people see what they would say
a lot of people like to go here but this
actually doesn't cause any problems
because we can trade and play c5 and
blacks perfectly fine you got to play c5
so what Karpov did and this is really
awesome okay I don't want you to take my
beep on b3
you can have my a pond and go way over
there okay
and now what makes this particularly
aesthetic I just played b3 before I
couldn't play b4 in the original
position because your Queen would take
it so b3 b4 and now the Queen you know
she she went to the bank she robbed the
bank took the loot now you got a you got
to get out take the money and then just
leave town that's what happens and
obviously now white gets the file and
the Queen had to go back so okay a lot
has changed now of the the course of a
few moves I did give up the file which
ended up costing me upon however I'm
still playing against this really bad
bishop and he figures that's worth upon
you have that bad bishop for the rest of
the game and okay good you got a pawn
great so to make sure again you're maybe
thinking about playing c5 so I play C 5
myself and now it's even better than in
the other variation without the rooks
that can come to d5 and you know extra
supported okay so black takes and I
wonder how would you guys take back here
these are sort of simple choices that
you have to make in the game of chess
you have two ways to take back and I
think there's pros and cons to both of
them but I really like the way that he
took back you want to take with a pond
okay why do you want to take with a pond
so your Queen can move okay and you're
thinking yeah maybe the Queen has a
great square you blockaded this pawn so
okay this guy is never going to move
that's the the obvious upside however
you do give black a passer which is kind
of kind of dangerous you know I think
maybe even immediately I'm thinking I'm
going to start pushing this guy and yeah
okay so you have to worry about this I
do have some counter play I still have a
bad piece but I'm up a pond and it's an
outside passer so you do have to be kind
of worried about that
so instead he took with his queen
which not only doesn't give black any
counter play okay we're threatening the
a7 pond and we have a threat and so once
you realize what your your threat is
here and you realize what black has to
play in this position then okay I think
you're going to like taking what the
Queen what am i threatening
b5 yeah tacking the pond and there's a
pin here on the C file so Pike had to
play the move a six not the move you
want it to play because your Bishop is
never getting out so let's see yeah
extra make sure that even in some lines
you know the bishop never even comes out
even if you give the pawn back or
whatever now he's really trapped in
there okay so you brought us queen in
we'll get to the next main part here
h4 okay maybe I'll do some stuff on the
other wing maybe I can you know get a
get a nice strong pawn here in black
plays h5 which actually turns out to be
a big mistake now here again this this
part is you know amazing as well and
I'll ask you first what the winning plan
is now for white can you imagine that he
already has a very very strong plan and
then for bonus credit what famous game
does that remind you of
they got no chance but but you got a
chance this game was played in 1992 does
that help you because you know the
famous 1991 game you remember who had
white a Nigel short okay good job we've
got a very strong audience all right cuz
we got Wally here tonight so he's pretty
good
yeah Nigel short that famous game does
anybody else know what what he did in
that game he had a very triumphant King
March over towards the the other King to
help assist in checkmate so the King
goes up to g3
so this was a year later so presumably
he knew that game and now a very
interesting moment in the game okay I
see you're going to bring your King in
and you're going to try to checkmate me
so I want to trade the Queens
and again you have to ask yourself we're
down upon
so should we trade Queens or should we
move our queen somewhere else and okay
the obvious question is if I trade
Queens do I win that's what you want to
see whenever they offer you a trade in
the position like this do I win do I win
if I trade Queens or do I need to keep
them on the board and keep playing
against your bed Bishop you need to keep
them on yeah it seems like yeah he's
gonna make a pastor on the Queen side
potentially um now to shock you he did
trade the Queens he's Karpov right and
right is its again it's a move you may
not consider just even on basis of
general rules don't trade when you're
down in material you trade when you're
up in material but all these rules you
know it always comes back to what the
concrete position is and you want to
think about the actual position and not
just whatever some dogmatic sentence
you've heard once and just do whatever
that is that's how you know a lot of
people are stuck in that and it prevents
them but so he had to see here a winning
plan in these Karpov so he figured it
out but it yeah it's not so obvious at
first okay
okay
so he saw a position like this and one
of the problems is if I'm ever going to
liberate this bishop you know without
losing a pond I'm going to have to get
my king over here somewhere to protect
the bishop and I can push one of the
bonds but you can never really do that
because I'm too fast over on this side
of the board and there actually is a
winning plan so let's pause here again
and you can pause it home for more time
can you find a winning plan for white
okay Bishop before and what's your plan
okay so you want to go here which was
played and you want to go take this okay
let me not do anything for a second did
you want to take it okay
you sure okay you're sure I took it
you're take all right
and if you take I'm I'm yeah I'm gonna
beat you
yeah so this actually you know it's an
idea that may occur this sacrifice is
something we do want to keep in mind but
we have to make sure we know what
Black's gonna do and he does he's really
quick I placed c5 and then I have a
passer f3 g4 awesome awesome what was
your name again
James that's good is this your first
class okay cool
g4 and this is the winning idea we're
going to break through because if you
take which was not played we can take
back and yeah we et cetera and if you
don't then I take twice on h5 so he went
here and okay so here okay the game ends
and also it's kind of funny he waits a
little bit tortures um just a little bit
and now black resigned so okay my king
goes back here and my pawn goes this way
if you go stop them with your king then
I get to enter and take all of your
stuff so a very instructive example by
Karpov breaking several rules that you
may know about trading and it yeah
turned out to be just fantastic he
thought concretely concretely about the
position was able to play against this
bad piece and keep the bishop trapped
for the duration of the entire game okay
now we're going to go on to another
example this one will be a lot quicker
we'll flip it so here's a position that
I just want to look at briefly this is
Alexi Gusev vs. Roswell Abram Imam I'm
not going to promise anything right
especially with a sore throat but it was
played in 2011
can you read those names
okay so in this position it's black to
move and what we want to do with this
exercise is we want to think about which
piece black wants to trade and then
figure out how to do it and to make this
work we really want to be thinking about
all of our pieces what are we going to
do with every single one of our pieces
what's the general plan so if you're
familiar with this pawn structure which
okay you want to be familiar with
certain pawn structures if you're going
to be playing them perhaps this move
will just come to you and I think this
is the kind of puzzle where either you
know this maneuver and you can see it in
one second or you don't know it and
you'll you'll never see it until you've
seen it for the first time so hopefully
for a lot of people this is a new idea
even though it's a very well known idea
so I'm going to give you guys a minute
or two and at home pause your videos get
a little more time we've got a lot of
firepower in the audience now so no it's
okay so we'll see you guys come up with
I'll give you guys a minute or do we
have any general ideas of where we'd
like to get some of our pieces yeah
okay yeah where might he want to go
maybe five right yeah maybe he wants to
go to c5 but obviously you know this
might end up ruining your pawn structure
so we do have to be careful with that
but that's that is the idea hidden in
this entire position
okay very good yeah two more yeah if you
can find a way to trade the dark-squared
bishop s-- then you'd be all set your
knight goes to c5 and that indeed is the
idea but the question now is how do you
do it how do I trade this guy for that
guy do you see it is there a tactical
way do you know this idea I'm sorry yeah
there you go okay awesome
yeah Bishop h6 was played completely
blundering a bishop until you see this
check so this is what was played in the
game and that's enough to say that you
solve the puzzle you achieved your
strategic aim and obviously unlike
tactical puzzles you know obviously the
game keeps going forever and ever and
black did ultimately win but that's just
a simple puzzle and okay even trading he
traded the Queen's and we'll just look
at kind of what happened all of his
pieces found really nice squares on the
dark squares so by trading the dark
squared bishop which was sometimes you
know it's a good attacking piece but
here he was just kind of blocked in by
the pawns and that gave him all these
dark squares on the Queen side so that's
where he put all of his pieces so good
that was very good
all right we're gonna look at another
one this game was played between Dorota
II wanna yoke
versus Levon Aronian yeah you heard
about the guy and it's flipped from his
perspective so who do who do we think
won in 2005 yeah possibly the guy 500
points higher rated that you've heard of
and we're
looking at it from his perspective okay
and the theme is trades and what's sort
of the obvious theme attic move in a
position like this what what should we
be looking for what's the question that
we should be asking ourself in this
position we want to control d5 yeah
that's in these types of positions
that's always huge typically the
liberating move d5 guarantees black
equality so that's definitely going to
be a part of this position but there's
something there's an immediate move that
we might be be looking for here what am
I thinking about yeah yeah right and
that's yeah that's the question so
whenever we have these Sicilians and
it'll probably be opposite side castling
otherwise black will just keep asking in
the center we always want to look at
this move rook takes e3 obviously you've
been told this piece is worth five and
that piece is worth three but okay we've
been on this theme of challenging these
normal assumptions and it's a very
typical attacking move so in this type
of position it's it's very normal to try
to calculate rook takes e3 does it work
or does white have a defense and what's
really funny is I tried to find
positions at one point this was like a
month ago or something I was like I'm
going to look at rook takes c3 and these
types of positions and I'm just going to
see like does it work or does it not and
in doing that I found like hundreds of
games and it's always good
you always play rook takes e3 you
believe that
all right good some people do some
people don't I hope you don't because
that's the whole point of the lecture
don't believe me just because I say that
right a lot of buildup for that joke um
but okay does it work
that's the big question so let's think
about it take a minute take a minute at
home look what he got there what he got
there what do you got there no we're
passing notes this is like elementary
school in here all right
you taking notes I'm just taking my time
because I guess we got we got hours to
kill here so just think about this for
like 30 minutes I'll be back and I guess
to just based on your intuition does it
feel like it works obviously we want to
take some time to calculate it but just
what do you guys feel instance we're in
grade school we can raise our hands who
wants to take the night nobody who
doesn't want to take the night a couple
people and most people are just sitting
there blankly okay in the game he did
take and joking aside it almost always
does work like it always play rook takes
c3 yeah I'm double tricking you now cuz
now you really should always play rook
takes c3 what's the whole point of this
lecture nobody knows okay and that's
exactly what he played which sort of
challenges the assumption that okay you
trade a five point piece for a 3-point
piece that can't be good but here super
top player went for it and we'll see he
gets a lot of pressure and he gets an
immediate attack and it works and he
wins so white has to be passive he
brings more pieces in and we'll just see
the end of this this attack so in this
position he's able to play the move that
we were hoping to play here the move d5
he crashes through that I get to
threaten matin one I get to threaten
Mayton one that one but i'm get to
threaten mate you can take and I take
back of my queen after you defend I get
to threaten mate a couple different ways
so he's sacrificed to help defend his
rook and
pretty soon here he just resigns because
he's down a lot of material so okay a
fantastic example this was a more
attacking kind of position but we got
keep you guys on your toes so throw some
some attacks in there and yeah okay I
mean so obviously when it's obvious it's
like castling sank these sacrifices are
you know a little more obvious than in
other positions but uh let's do another
this is the game between Mexi Mugi and
Boris Gelfand Boris here has the black
pieces we'll be looking at it from his
point of view and this was played in
1989 okay and so again I guess before we
give any hints or advice here I want you
guys to try to assess it this is the
tough one I think this one's a lot
tougher than any of the other examples
if you've just joined us it is the theme
is sort of trading and also you know
sort of challenging typical chests Dogma
over what you should trade and why and
when and etc so that's that's a pretty
big hand but I'll give you guys Elson I
kind of want to here is black better
where's equal why why not what are the
how can i how can I say this non
politically what are the advantages yeah
Bishop takes on c3 did that come quite
easily to you or was it the hint
right yes sir okay he wants to take
tonight because there's a big pin here
did you notice you're down upon okay so
you're down upon you're a lot more
developed white still is a little ways
from castling so we do want to do
something immediately because if he
plays Bishop b2 and castles then we're
down upon so this move does come to mind
and this may seem very strange because
you normally don't give up your best
awesome all-star bishop especially not
for a knight and here we're you know we
can take back two different ways so so a
very interesting decision and a very
good one and in the game he took back
with the pawn if you take back with the
rook I take on a two not only getting my
pawn back but it's surprisingly
difficult to defend your beep on because
if you put your queen or rook on c2 you
got to worry about night before no move
like this you need to be worried about
Knight to b3 and if you try to play a
move like b3 seems sensible enough well
now that you've given me access here
it's gonna be difficult for you to
castle because even if you play Bishop
e2 and Castle then your bishops hanging
so for that reason he took back with a
pawn and it would be very easy to snatch
the pawn on a2 but he instead decides to
develop more pieces and go after the guy
on c4 his next move is going to be 95
and then he's going to take on c4 okay
and there's a little bit more to this
puzzle so white defends and black goes
through with his plan he attacks the c-4
pawn
now he takes and now in this position so
this actually is is pretty cool here I
think this is where you might want to
pause now because I'm gonna give some
hints but you may want to take your time
think about this position can you play
one of the two winning moves there's two
winning moves here and they're both
awesome and spectacular he played the
second best move which also wins and
it's a little more spectacular than the
best move so okay I will give you guys a
second and we'll talk about it give you
guys some hints if we need to this is
this is obviously this is the hardest
puzzle of the day what's best move here
have you figured it out all right what
move will move left to your mind you
can't say no to write your Jessica Lee
not supposed to do it yeah interesting
yeah that's too much of a hint no I've
been telling that this the whole time
obviously it's moves that challenge the
way that you typically think about the
game in the position and you play moves
that you wouldn't normally play right
yeah right and right it really takes
your opponent by surprise because it so
I think perhaps some people in the
audience have have figured out what was
played but also there's an even stronger
move he played the move of that I think
you're thinking about but yeah but
there's an even stronger move
which which 1g5 this was played in the
game yeah g5 yeah right always moving
the the G pawns right so the point is
when you take back there's going to be a
check and then we're going to be able to
grab the bishop
however the strongest move and again you
can pause at home but it's really tough
you can actually play the move Knight a
four and you're threatening to trap the
Queen so some random move the Queen is
trapped
so what White has to do is take here and
then he's not going to be able to castle
you're just going to bring your rook in
and okay this is just crushing for for
black here and okay obviously in a
position like this after they play E - I
think a lot of people just instinctually
bring their last piece into the game and
okay if you let me castle but obviously
this still is better for black but he
went for a more immediate solution which
you know the very exciting move here g5
you know move to it you don't normally
move your pawns in front of your king
and it's hanging I'm going to take it so
he toss this check in and you grab the
bishop and okay we'll enjoy the the end
of the game here
you can take two different pawns he went
here now if you Castle 93 which is what
happened so okay he's going to lose some
material okay this is now just winning
here for black and for a top Grandmaster
it wasn't more than you know technical
victory from that point so right so even
seeing this even if you you were able to
consider this move which you would this
is the move that sort of started at all
trading you know the greatest Bishop of
all time whenever you play the
fianchetto variations and you have that
super long diagonal for a piece here
that looks like it can be captured three
different ways is it's sort of startling
it's something that you may not expect
and that's again that's the whole point
of the lecture sort of challenging rules
of a trading that you've heard and it's
it's again it's always about the
concrete positions that you have in
front of you so if you liked it let me
know in the comments below like share
subscribe challenge dogma see you next
week
Oh